[موسيقى]
ما بين القفص الذهبي وشبك العزوبيه تدور
احداث ملايين البشر
فحلموا الارتباط بشريك الحياه لم يعد
الاجمل لدى كثيرين حيث كشفت دراسه حديثه
ان ثمه ما يزيد من اعداد الاشخاص غير
القادرين على الارتباط
فالتغيرات والمجتمعيه القت بظلالها على
الزوج المثالي اضافه لضعف مهارات الحفاظ
على العلاقه من اجواء الرومانسيه وتناغم
واتفاق العزوبيه اذا قرار وليس خيار قرار
يتخطى به كثيرون مؤسسه الزواج التي يجب ان
تقوم على اسس النقاش والتفاوض وحل الخلاف
والمغازله الزوجيه والعواطف الدراسه اضافت
ايضا بان اسباب صعوبه العثور على شريك
حياه تتوقف عند الخلافات بين الزوجين
وتعديها الى افتقارهما لاسس حل المشاكل
اذا قد يكون الحب موجودا لكن استمراره صعب
الا في حال عوده الكلمه الطيبه والصبر
كسيد للمواقف عند مناقشه اي خلاف بين
الزوجين